до тех пор пока этот режим у власти
война может быть приостановлена на
какое-то время Не надо подтолкивать
украинцев в спину в сторону
самоубийственной атаки без наличия
соответствующих объёмов
вооружений техники Как вы считаете ну
громко говоря народ безмол стоит не
выходит на улицу не оказывается
противление на улицу то с оружием в
руках до этого ещё какое-то время какое
я ожидаю что
либо Украина с умеет победить либо Путин
умрёт пана ходорковский пас на охоплює
відчай або безвихідь коли ви
спостерігаєте за тим що нині
відбувається в Росії
Провівши 10 років у в'язниці з
очікуванням того що це триватиме все
життя я усі ступені вічаю та виході
пройшов і на нинішню ситуацію їх уже не
вистачає тож Ні я оптиміст і темніє
Почему Как вы считаете тим не менше як
ви вважаєте чому народ у Росії мовчить
не виходить на вулиці не протестує адже
навіть у радянські часи коли СРСР воював
у Афганістані був Хоч якийсь рух
протесту А зараз узагалі нуль
є согласился Я би з вами не погодився
по-перше причину з якою народ не
виходить на вулиці і не виступає масово
проти влади мені тут у Німеччині нікому
пояснювати не треба
ви жили За тоталітарного режиму і як
ніхто розумієте Як тоталітарний режим
впливає на суспільство
з іншого боку сьогоднішня Росія - це
навіть не Радянський Союз
під час соціологічних опитувань де
зрозуміло що люди побоюються
висловлювати свої реальні думки тим не
менш від 10 до 15% респондентів прямо
кажуть що вони проти війни
це значно більше ніж Можна було б уявити
у такій ситуації
звісно акції протесту в Росії доволі
багато інша річ що влада ретельно
охороняє ті місця де можуть бути
зроблені записи таких акцій міжнародними
кореспондентами А так протестів вистачає
записі міжнародного кореспондентами оно
так протест хватает А у вас есть
пропозиція як дати цьому протесту
обличчя мирними прогулянками
індивідуальними пікетами аккціями в
інтернеті
я не хотел бы я не хотів би виступати
людиною котра без змістовно тобто без
реальної можливості поміняти цю владу
пропонуватиме людям підставити себе під
нинішній вже крокодилячі терміни
тюремного ув'язнення Мій товариш карам
Морзе отримав 25 років позбавлення волі
який цей режим не існуватиме Але тим не
менше зрозуміло що він сидітиме у
в'язниці поки Путін буде при владі
виходити на вулиці щоб помахати кульками
і ліхта І за це утримати 25 років Навіщо
це потрібно якщо вже виходити на вулиці
то зі зброєю в руках до цього має минути
ще якийсь час
який
я
очікую що або Україна зможе перемогти
або Путін помре
лібик
в Германии сейчас тут у Німеччині нині
переважає точка зору що хай росіяни там
собі борються з режимом запроваджуються
жорсткі заходи з обмеження видавання віз
росіянам у тому числі супротивникам
режиму Як ви ставитеся до такої практики
каждая страна Имеет право кожна країна
має право робити те що вона вважає за
потрібне Навіть якщо це дурниця я
подивився як сучасна Німеччина
поставилася б до практики повернення
євреїв у фашистську Німеччину щоб вони
згнили у концтаборах може комусь це
видається непоганою ідеєю але мені трохи
по-іншому люди які виступають проти
путінського режиму повертаючись до Росії
має два можливих варіанти служити режиму
або йти у в'язницю треба розуміти що
жодної можливості боротися за
відсутності зброї і за поки що достатньо
контрольованих владою силових структур
просто не існує з іншого боку зараз
Німеччина як і багато інших західних
країн зазнає величезних витрат
пов'язаних із санкціями які
застосовуються до цього режиму які
ускладнюють йому проведення війни так
ось одна з найсильніших санкцій це
відтік молодого освіченого населення на
відміну від інших санкцій таких як
заборона на постачання товарів
заборонено купівлю енергоносіїв ця
санкція справді була б вигідна західним
країнам тому що кваліфікованих людей
яких можна легко інтегрувати в західне
суспільство якими є росіяни котрі
виїздять завжди бракує
ви сказали от двух возможностях И
сказали про дві можливості або
отримувати режим або йти у в'язницю є ще
Третій шлях емігрувати що зараз роблять
дуже багато росіян які не сходні з
режимом як у роль ви віддаєте їм То що
можуть робити ці люди виїжджаючи з Росії
по-перше вони забирають із собою знання
і вміння які режим сьогодні намагається
перетворити на виробництво дедалі
більших обсягів зброї вони забирають Ті
руки які цей режим намагається
відправити на фронт воювати з Україною з
іншого боку ці люди приносять у західне
суспільство ці самі знання і вміння вони
дуже активні їм хочеться досягти якихось
результатів продовжувати своє життя
кар'єру зрозуміло що якщо цей режим
проіснує ще десятиліття то потім ці люди
в Росію звісно не повернуться але якщо
як ми припускаємо до кінця цього режиму
лишилося від 5 до 10 років максимум
радше 5 ніж 10 то ці люди повернуться
Росію і тут треба дуже добре подумати
єдине чого не можна змінити це те що ми
завжди залишатимемося з сусідами на
цьому континенті і від того якими
сьогодні будуть відносини з
орієнтованими на захід росіянами
залежатиме як ці відносини складуться з
тією Росією котра буде після Путіна і
куди ці люди повернуться дуже важливо на
мій погляд щоб сьогодні вони відчули що
тут вони свої вони ті кого приймають і
підтримують і тоді цілком можна
розраховувати на взаємність коли
ситуація зміниться
А какое ви бачите роль політичної
еміграції вашої та інших організацій
російських політемігрантів які в них є
можливості впливати на суспільні настрої
в Росії чи є вони взагалі на
сьогоднішній день
Сьогодні ці можливості обмежені адже ми
не в тій ситуації яка була в минулому
столітті коли можна було створити
підпільні організації і то не над
виходило поки режим не починав падати
тим не менш У нас є інші можливості У
нас є можливості contro пропаганди
можливості роботи з російським
суспільством моя щомісячна аудиторія в
Росії становить десятки мільйонів людей
коли я кажу моя то маю на увазі тих ЗМІ
які зі мною працюють
70% цієї аудиторії сьогодні перебувають
у Росії і вони слухають і переглядають
ту продукцію яку ми їм пропонуємо це
важливо тому що ця продукція нищить
наративи путінської пропаганди змушуючи
путінський режим наприклад побоюватися
проведення масової мобілізації
побоюватися того що у великих містах
може виникнути неконтрольована ситуація
і тримати там додаткові збройні сили які
в іншому разі режим міг би легко
спрямувати на фронт Сьогодні ми
Закликаємо людей до індивідуального
саботажу не зібраного в якісь ієрархічні
структури в XXI столітті будь-яка
ієрархічна структура буде одразу
виявлена і знищена а з індивідуальним
саботажем режим нічого не зможе зробити
з індивідуальним суботажем режимні
можуть ничего на вашу думку як може
закінчитися війна Росії проти України і
що потрібно для того щоб Україна
перемогла давець
скажемо Давайте скажемо що існує те чого
ми всі бажаємо що є для нас символами
віри це агресивна війна режим Злочинний
Україна в кордонах 1991 року це те чого
ми всі хотіли припинити агресивну війну
покарати Злочинний режим і повернути
статус кводу міжнародну визнаних
кордонів України з іншого боку існує
ситуація як ми її бачимо сьогодні
кількість зброї та боєприпасів які нині
постачають Україні приблизно в 10 разів
менше ніж та кількість озброєнь яку
путінський режим може постачати на фронт
західне озброєння часто просунути але
його в 10 разів менше Ні це неможливо
подолати окрім того в Україні значно
менші мобілізаційні ресурси ніж у Путіна
тому саме зараз напередодні потенційних
наступальних або контрнаступальних дій
заходу важливо вирішити чого він хоче
насправді він хоче щоб Україна перемогла
тоді потрібні літаки пілоти танки
постачання значних обсягів зброї або
захід хоче щоб ситуація стабілізувалася
на тому рівні на якому вона перебуває
нині У цьому разі не треба підштовхувати
українців у спину у бік самогубчої атаки
без наявності відповідних обсягів
озброєнь і техніки
ви вважаєте що ця війна повинна і може
закінчитися на полі бою а не в
результаті переговорів мирних
переговорів так чи інакше
любая война будь-яка війна крім
останньої закінчиться в результаті
переговорів інших елементів людство не
вигадало або стовідсотковий геноцид у
результаті якого знищується на 100% одна
з держав або переговори Я сподіваюся що
перший варіант зараз не розглядається у
цій ситуації Питання в тому на що готові
і згодні українці як довго і в яких
умовах вони готові воювати Що стосується
російської сторони то Я глибоко
переконаний що закінчення війни буде
пов'язана тільки зі зміною режиму поки
цей режим при владі війна може бути
призупинена на якийсь час самі подумайте
Путін уже чотири рази за свою політичну
кар'єру вирішував свої електоральні
проблеми за допомогою війни він і уп'яте
буде так само їх вирішувати ми розуміємо
що від електоральних проблем у
тоталітарному сенсі йдеться про базу
підтримки а не про реальні вибори йому
нікуди не подітися тому що захоплені
українські території для Путіна це не
актив А пасив ці території треба
відновлювати людей треба годувати вони
нічого не дадуть а економіка в Росії вже
10 років як стагнує не існує жодних
підстав для того аби вона припинила
стегновати в умовах продовження санкцій
Таким чином для Путіна не існує інших
варіантів окрім продовження війни мляве
або активне домовитися з ним можна
тільки про якесь перемир’я потрібно це
чи ні вирішувати українцям Дякуємо
Михайла борисовичу